so if you're just joining us here we're
going to recap our breaking news coming
out of Lebanon where an Israeli drone
has assassinated Sal arui a senior
official from Hamas at least four people
died in the strike which took place in
the southern part of lebanon's capital
Beirut the office was located in the
suburb of deya Ali Hashim is live for us
now in nakura in southern Lebanon so Ali
what more are you hearing and and how
significant is this
development
well hzim um as you said this
assassination of Deputy poit Bureau of
Hamas along with three of his assistants
in uh an explosion till the moment we
don't have any confirmation whether this
was a drone attack whether this was an
explosion a bomb planted in the office
or a war plane till the moment there are
no clear uh uh there's no clear picture
on how this was conducted though there
are many that are saying it's likely a
drone attack and if it's a drone attack
then this is the first time since 2006
in Beirut uh the other thing is that is
significance within Hamas he's he's the
the liazon between the uh military wing
and the political uh Bureau he is the
man who is known to be one of the
founders of the military wing of alam
brigades he was uh in Israeli prisons
for 15 years since the '90s and till
2010 when he was released then he left
to Syria and from Syria to Turkey and
from Turkey back came to Lebanon where
he was assassinated today the
significance of this assassination is
that it puts or it stresses the fact
that this whole war that started on the
7th of October 2023 is a multi-layered
war a war that's already being raged on
on on on Gaza people being killed in
Gaza at the same time it's a security
war and multiple uh fronts one of them
is Lebanon and actually this puts the
assassination
of into also another dimension there is
the Hamas Dimension and there is the
Lebanon Dimension and there's theah
Dimension especially with the Secretary
General ofah
vowing in in in in the past months and
and years that any um Israeli
assassination to any of the resistance
leaders as he said is going to be uh
faced with retaliation and a harsh
retaliation now we'll all be waiting to
see what nasah is supposed to say in a
speech that was still before the
assassination of harui was planned for
tomorrow now we don't know if this
speech is going to continue as scheduled
tomorrow or it's going to be postponed
for another couple of days for hisbah to
weigh its options because actually this
is kind of a a turning point in the
whole confrontation with respect to the
Lebanese the Lebanese front uh for the
for the for the front in Gaza it's just
part of this whole context but for the
Lebanese front it's it could be a
trigger for something bigger especially
that it comes a week after another
assassination in Damascus Israel is
trying to take this whole
confrontation uh to a new to a new space
and this could mean not containing this
war actually many thought that the
assassination of a senior Hamas leader
could could end this war but the fact is
that the assassination of a senior Hamas
leader in Beirut could trigger a new new
dramatic uh uh uh context and this is
what many right now are really think
thinking observers can't really analyze
in such in such a moment so uhi was
assassinated as we reported he's a
senior Hamas Commander he's a senior
Hamas official and you know the the
irony here is that Israel wasn't able to
Assassin or kill any of the major or or
senior Hamas uh officials and commanders
in its three months war in Gaza at the
end it came and killed uh one of hamas's
leaders in Beirut this is this is one of
the ironies of this war and Ali you're
talking to us uh from nakura in southern
Lebanon where you've been reporting for
several days now on the ongoing uh
clashes between hasah forces in southern
Lebanon uh and uh Israel uh what
implications is is the news of this uh
apparent assassination going to have uh
for for that aspect of of of the
conflict you know uh hzim there were
Rules of Engagement that we've been
referring to all over the past three
months Rules of Engagement whereas
hisbah is hitting uh uh within 3 to 5
kilometers sometimes 10 kilometers
inside the Israeli territories and
Israel hitting also within the Lebanese
territ territories towards the Lani
river which is like in in in a depth of
15 to 20 kilomet maximum but today
there's something outside the box
there's something outside the whole
Rules of Engagement and this at least
given the fact that hisbah committed to
that in the past this could mean and but
we don't have a clear answer but this
could mean if I want to if we want to
analyze that hasah is going to uh
respond from outside the Rules of
Engagement and what would this mean this
is this this is the big question how is
this going to uh to end is it going to
end just with this hit hit for a hit it
for that or this is going to widen the
scope of the war this is what many
people are actually concerned of and you
know in the past in the past few weeks
people were leaving South Lebanon and
according to United Nations numbers
there are more than 70,000 Southerners
who are not anymore in their homes at
the border but now with a hit inside
Beirut in in the southern suburb of
Beirut this is another reason for people
to be concerned and for civilians to be
feeling unsafe unsafe anywhere whether
it's it's in the South or in Beirut and
this takes this whole confrontation as
we've been saying into a new dimension
all right for the moment Ali Hashim in
nakur in Lebanon let's go to z h who
joins us on the line now from Beirut so
Z you reported extensively uh from the
Lebanese capital for many years now uh
targeted assassinations as this
certainly appears to be are
unfortunately nothing new uh in bayut
but what do you make of uh uh what has
happened here over the last
hour well nothing new but the first
assassination in years and once news
broke of an explosion in the southern
suburbs of Beirut which is an area where
hasal holds sway I can tell you uh there
was Panic there was panic in the
Lebanese the Lebanese know what what
this means um there were reports of a
targeted strike a targeted assassination
a serious escalation it definitely
escalated and widened the ongoing
conflict along the Lebanon Israel border
the the conflict along the border is is
now it's it's going to enter it its
fourth months um but the targeted
killing made many people here in the
capital feel that this conflict could
widen and could escalate and all eyes
are now on hasbalah hezbollah's reaction
because even before Hezbollah joined the
battle to support its Ally um Hamas in
Gaza uh the Secretary General of
hasbalah Hassan Nella made it very very
clear and his equation was um there will
be a fierce retaliation if any leader of
the axis of resistance whether it's a
Syrian a Palestinian a Lebanese an
Iranian any leader killed in Lebanon
will trigger a fierce uh reaction so
people are waiting to hear um well the
Secretary General Nella was is supposed
to speak tomorrow it was a planned
speech to commemorate the killing of the
uh the Iranian C Force leader Kum Su
Mani but there are some reports now that
that speech could be cancelled so it
will really depend whether this the
serious escalation will lead to a
fullscale conflict now many in Lebanon
will tell you that Israel is trying to
trigger a conflict um it has been
escalating it
in in southern Lebanon and but
definitely this assassination crosses
the red line and and
assassination breaks really The Rules of
Engagement which have been in place for
for three months now so all eyes on
what will do foll the killing of arri
and we have to point out that it's not
just Salah Ari who was killed um he was
killed along with a number of military
commanders and so this was a a serious
blow to hamas's military infrastructure
if you like in
one and Zena just give us a sense of uh
how much of a presence uh Hamas had uh
not just in Beirut but in in in Lebanon
in in general what was the role uh that
Hamas operatives played
there well as of late Lebanon became a
if you like for the leaders of Hamas as
of late it became u a strategic base for
Hamas after the rer of SCH between Hamas
and Hezbollah a few years back there was
a falling out um following conflict in
Syria since then they have been slowly U
build infrastructure the political
presence in the country Hezbollah and
Hamas close coordinate with each other
since the conflict along the border
began we've seen several meetings you
know between as well as Secretary
General Hass as well as with uh the
assassinated Deputy leader of of Hamas
aruri uh so so you had this close
coordination and in many ways uh you
know they they were living and working
uh in in the southern suburbs of Beirut
um you know some some would call this a
HB stronghold but this is a place where
half a million people live uh we are
standing very close to the to the site
of that explosion and I can tell you you
know you you you look at people's faces
there there's fear and concern about
what could come come next because this
was what what everyone was worried about
the conflict um along the border um
widening and um but but clear clearly
this this really is in in many ways a
turning point but we have to see H to
see whether or not this serious
escalation will lead to a fullscale uh
conflict between the Israeli Army and
the Lebanese armed group has
below all right for the moment Zena hod
on the line for there uh from Beirut
thanks very much Z